emotional house hearing on President
Biden's botched Afghanistan withdrawal
marine sniper who survived the deadly
bomb record Bulls Airport
says he could have stopped the Isis
suicide bomber who killed 13 service
members and countless afghans
a requested engagement Authority while
my team leader was ready on the m110
semi-automatic sniper system the
response leadership did not have the
engagement Authority for us do not
engage plain and simple we were ignored
our expertise was disregarded no one was
held accountable for our safety then a
Flash and a massive wave of pressure
I'm throwing 12 feet onto the ground but
instantly knew what had happened I
opened my eyes to Marines dead or
unconscious lying around me
the withdrawal
the withdrawal was a catastrophe in my
opinion
and there was an inexcusable lack of
accountability and negligence
so Sandra I mean the actual policy
decision isn't the argument here most of
us have accepted that this war had to
end but it was how it was carried out
um you know what are your thoughts on
this negligence I mean extreme lack of
accountability as a result plain and
simple we were ignored that's
heartbreaking testimony our expertise
was disregarded no one was held
accountable for our safety but let's now
go to the nearly 7.2 billion dollars
worth of aircraft guns vehicle
ammunition specialized equipment that
has fallen into the hands of the Taliban
78 aircraft worth 923 million dollars I
mean just think about that alone as a
result of this chaotic withdrawal from
Afghanistan furthermore the taliban's
recruiting former Afghan military
personnel I mean think about the actual
real world consequences this far out now
that we are now suffering that has put
us in Jeopardy and Us in Peril as a
result of that chaotic withdrawal that's
interesting too I was just thinking uh I
was going to ask you about that Jesse
about the equipment have we seen them
use it yet like the planes do we are
they just simply just is it like I doubt
they have the expertise to fly our Jets
yeah but they probably can use some of
the artillery some of the tanks some of
the weaponry
but what was it how many billions did we
leave over there I mean we probably
could have taken that and then sold it
to the ukrainians and saved a little bit
of a discount and we do know that Putin
saw that chaotic withdrawal and that
encouraged him to invade Ukraine because
he sensed weakness on behalf of the
United States so Biden Cuts this side
deal with the Taliban for the Evac and
says we're not going to shoot you you
don't shoot us let's do this thing in
Kabul but there were no rules of
engagement hammered out so if someone
saw a threat and they went up the food
chain for approval no one knew what to
say so none of these men needed to die
and then the state department shuts down
the processing of these guys into planes
at dark so once the sun goes down people
start piling up at the airport around
the barbed wire and they're trapped and
then it's chaos and they're slitting
their throats against the barbed wire
because they're too afraid to go back to
the Taliban because that torture is
going to be worth than the barbed wire
and no one's been fired and the
Democrats never even really investigated
this did they so we poured billions and
dollars into this stupid country we left
the Taliban with tons of equipment we
have tons of people dead wounded no legs
no arms I'm not sure we have a lot to
show for it so far though there hasn't
been any of those over Horizon attacks
that we were worried about if we ever
did leave yeah judge it's kind of sad I
mean to know that though that that he
had had an eyeball on the homicidal
bomber and it could have been prevented
but it wasn't you know this was a
failure of Epic Proportions this was a
an a particular foreign policy disaster
that will go down in history as one of
the worst the first was a decision to
leave the Bagram Air Force Base which
was a protected very sophisticated Air
Force Base they decide they're going to
do the evacuation from the middle of a
city in Kabul of four million people
with one Airway uh and the and the truth
is that this guy that was just
testifying his minus limbs he's had 44
surgeries they had credible information
of a potential suicide bomber they
actually had credible information and
they identified him they had what they
call the assured their leaders of the
ease of fire they had the what do you
call it the m110 uh sniper guy ready and
they didn't get an answer look a cop in
New York City has more of an ability to
shoot someone than we do in the in the
in a war in the theater of war in in in
Afghanistan and that's the sad part of
all this so you've got 13 gold star
families you've got 170 Afghans who were
killed as a result of an act that didn't
have to happen they could have stopped
the suicide bomber but they created the
chaos they picked the setting and this
guy Donahue was a two-star general you
know we remember seeing him he was the
last guy to go on that C-130 or whatever
it was nobody is accountable nobody's
answerable they make Donahue a
three-star general of Fort Bragg where
this year I hear there's something like
109 uh uh people in the military who are
dead either from fentanyl murder suicide
it's a disaster there's no
accountability and the sad part is if
they had Rules of Engagement they could
have taken it out and prevented it all
right last word to you Harold Wars are
messy uh my prayers go out to this uh
Sergeant Marine Sergeant Tyler of Vargas
Andrews I think if you were to interview
um any military personnel after a
mistake has been made or after mistakes
were made you would get you would get
testimony like this in fact our whole
premise for going into Iraq in that uh
Saddam Hussein possessed weapons of mass
destruction was wrong it was faulty so
we have a history of making mistakes at
critical times this is not to blame
anyone this is not to suggest that
anyone had the worst intentions or bad
intentions what I take from all of this
and I don't disagree but we can all the
things that have been said about the
table I take from what do we learn from
this we're now our pastor in Ukraine is
essentially one of War where we're
providing materials Personnel I mean
technology and weaponry to go after
Russia we find China on the verge of
perhaps invading Taiwan what have we
learned from these things and I would
ask perhaps the most the second most
immediate question from a national
security standpoint if Mexico cannot
police its cartels what is our military
strategy to help how do we learn from
the from the mistakes made in
Afghanistan the mistakes made in Iraq
and even the mistakes we're making real
time in Ukraine to ensure that going
forward we don't make the same mistakes
the problem is we always say
able it got credible information eyes on
the target a crowded chaotic theater and
you can take them out but I don't need
any lessons we need we need a military
and not a political decision
there were mistakes made but you know I
were in that room as they listened to
that evidence and made those decisions
those military personnel they clearly
made wrong ones or someone they could
have made different ones but I'm not
going to second-guess someone when I was
not in that room well I can second guess
13 deaths of American servicemen and 170
Afghans I regret it like you do judge hi
everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now